في المقدمة الآن كريس جاكسون غيتي إيمدجز
المصور الملكي الذي غطى الملكة
لما يقرب من عقدين من الزمن وهو مؤلف
إليزابيث ملكة في عصرنا
بالطبع لقد التقطت الكثير من صور الملكة
إليزابيث التي رأيناها خلال السنوات التي
أردت عرضها  واحدة كانت واحدة من
آخر صورها الرسمية التي التقطتها
بالفعل في وقت سابق من هذا العام ، أحب
ابتسامتها هنا مع صندوقها الأحمر الشهير
، ثم كانت الصورة الرسمية
للذكرى الأخيرة التي احتفلت
بها لزوجها ، هذه الصورة هنا مع
الأمير فيليب كانت  مرة أخرى في عام 2020. ما
كان يشبه تصوير الملكة
التي تعرف أنها تبدو كأنها
مبتذلة قليلاً لكنها كانت مبدعة وفي كل مرة
أتيحت لي الفرصة
لالتقاط صورة للملكة كانت مميزة
للغاية في السنوات الأخيرة.
مشكلات التنقل
وأنت تعرف عددًا أقل من
المشاركات العامة المتكررة ، لم يكن الأمر كذلك في كثير من الأحيان ولكن في
كل مرة أتيحت لي الفرصة ، كان الأمر
مميزًا جدًا
حقًا وامتيازًا كبيرًا
تم التقاط تلك الصورة المعينة التي كنت تتحدث عنها عن الصورة ذات الصندوق الأحمر في
وقت سابق من هذا العام
للاحتفال بيوم انضمامها
وأيضًا
لإحياء ذكرى بداية
اليوبيل البلاتيني وأنت تعلم أنك
تعرف أنه لخصت حقًا بالنسبة لي
التزامها بواجبها ودورها
، كان من المميّز للغاية
رؤية هذا التفاني بشكل مباشر ، لا أعلم
أنك شاركت بعض الصور الأخرى التي
استمتعت بها والتي تُظهرها كإنسان
والملكة تضحك جنبًا إلى جنب مع ابنها الآن
الملك تشارلز الثالث  في ألعاب Highland Games
في اسكتلندا ، تعلم أنك ترى أه ثم
الأمير تشارلز بجانبها وهذه
الصورة بالذات كنت الشخص الذي
التقط قوس قزح الذي تحدثنا
عنه بالأمس والذي كان هناك
حيث تم الإعلان عن وفاتها كنت في
لندن اليوم King  وصل تشارلز لأول مرة إلى
قصر باكنغهام بعد وفاة والدته
وكنت هناك الآن أعلم أنك
صورته أكثر من أي
فرد آخر في العائلة المالكة ، فماذا
تتوقع؟  سأقوم بتغطيته الآن ،
كما تقول ، لقد أمضيت
وقتًا طويلاً في مجال فنون الوجه
وأمير ويلز أحب الفوتوشوب وهو دائمًا
يجلب الطاقة الحقيقية لجميع
ارتباطاته وأعتقد أنك تعلم
بالطبع أن الأشياء لديها  تغير الآن ، فهو
الملك
ولكني أعتقد أنه سيستمر في عمله ،
أنت تعرف تفانيه المميز
في العمل
، ومن المؤكد أنه سافر حول
العالم قابله ، ويقول الكثير من الناس إنه رجل ذو
خبرة ولديه عمق كبير من
المعرفة حول مواضيع مختلفة و  هذا
هو الدور الذي وُلد
لتوليه ، لذا أعتقد أنني سأستمر في
تصويره بالطبع بالتقاط
صور له اليوم مع
قرينة الملكة كاميلا خارج
قصر باكنغهام في أول يوم له على ما أعتقد كملك
تشارلز أه هل تعرف ماذا  أنت تقوم
كمصور ملكي بالتقاط تلك
اللحظات التاريخية وشعرت وكأنها
لحظة خاصة
غريبة